black holes
we're riveted by their destructive power
black holes are dangerous black holes
are hazards black holes are not friendly
for their environments
there's just no good ends to anything
that falls into a black hole perhaps one
of the most frightening objects in the
universe
[Music]
but what exactly are these scary objects
black holes are created when you get
enough matter in a small region of space
this happens when a massive star dies
and collapses in on itself
a supernova
a black hole is the ultimate consequence
of gravity is an object that has so much
mass crushed into such a small space
that its Escape philosophy becomes
greater than the speed of light
[Music]
they are a one-way Street
you go in nothing escapes not even light
but do black holes really deserve their
bad rap
in some ways I think we set up black
holes to be more villains than they
actually are black holes suffer a bit of
a PR problem
I think they're a lot more menacing in
science fiction and popular media than
they really are
[Music]
there are trillions of galaxies in the
known universe
and most of them have a super massive
black hole at their Center
these monsters are millions of times the
mass of our sun
their immense gravity can send Stars
flying they're instrumental in
choreographing the dance of stars in
their vicinity
supermassive black holes shoot out
torrents of lethal radiation and violent
Cosmic winds
gobble up anything that comes close
now scientists are beginning to realize
these Cosmic Giants may also have a
creative side
most people think of black holes as
being like giant vacuum cleaners in
space and basically everything falls
into them but that's that's not actually
the case they're better thought of as
the engines of cosmic change
although black holes are the end states
of stars they can actually influence the
formation of stars as well in a bunch of
different ways
a Galaxy's job is to make stars
but uncontrolled star growth isn't
healthy
too many stars can drain a Galaxy's gas
supply
black holes are very important it
appears that Galaxy evolution is tied to
Black Hole Evolution we don't know
exactly how yet but
the marriage appears certain
one idea is that supermassive black
holes
act as Cosmic control mechanisms
black holes can act like a thermostat in
your house if your house gets too hot
the thermostat will kick on the air
conditioner and if it gets too cold
it'll kick on the heater black holes do
the same things for Galaxies
supermassive black holes regulate star
formation by pulling gas in and shooting
it back out into the Galaxy
when these black holes are consuming
matter their drawing matter into
themselves but they're also spewing
stuff out
basically black holes eat like little
babies very sloppily so a lot of it when
the eat comes flying back out again
big stars they eat planets but most
often they eat giant clouds of gas
the black hole drags gas and dust into
an accretion disk around it this disc
spins faster and faster
magnetic energy builds up
with the accretion just swirling around
the black hole there are also magnetic
fields that are going on the material is
moving so rapidly that the magnetic
field sort of winds up coils up and
forms a Vortex like a tornado
astronomers call them Jets
[Music]
these Jets propagate outward like
freight trains plowing through the
Galaxy over hundreds and thousands of
light years
these are like death rays
the Jets disrupt the star-forming gas
clouds limiting excess star formation in
the main body of the Galaxy
but in the very outer reaches of the
Galaxy they can spark star birth
more gentle out there you're not as
close to the energetic heart so stars
planets and life can form out there Park
IL that the black hole has moved out
there
so black holes can have outsized
influence on the regions that they
inhabit right around them they can
prevent the formation of stars whereas
on very very large scales they can
actually instigate the formation of
stars
[Music]
2018 black holes hit the front page
scientists discovered black holes
gobbling up gas so fast that they seem
to be outgrowing their host galaxies
it naturally makes the question come up
how big can a black hole get thank you
now we have the answer they can reach
size triple XL becoming Ultra massive
black holes
[Music]
Ultra massive black holes are so cool
because it's just mind-boggling that
black holes so large can exist Ultra
massive black holes are very rare and
typically have masses of more than 10
billion times the mass of the Sun 10
billion solar masses that's a 10
followed by nine zeros Ultra massive
black holes are real beasts
the black hole at the center of our
galaxy is 4 million solar masses imagine
black holes that are 2500 times bigger
that's what we're talking about here
[Music]
an ultra massive black hole this big
would be as wide as the solar system
and weigh as much as all the stars in
the Milky Way
[Music]
that really surprised the hell out of
everybody
and in 2018
scientists discover a 20 billion solar
mass Ultra massive black hole growing
faster than any other black hole
it's ravenous Behemoth devours the mass
of our sun every two days
these big black holes are really good at
gobbling up other things that literally
eat anything they're Monsters of the
universe
this kind of voracious eating can have
devastating consequences
[Music]
it blasts so much energy and turbulence
into the Galaxy that stars no longer
form
the bigger the black hole the faster the
Galaxy dies
the primary thing these Ultra massive
black holes do to galaxies is they shut
down All-Star formation and so in that
sense they kind of kill galaxies and so
these things could even wipe out their
host galaxies
Ultra massive black holes are a problem
for scientists too
they might be the fastest eaters
but that doesn't explain how they got so
large
with these Ultra massive black holes
these black holes that are tens of
billions of times more massive than our
sun you can't just grow them from the
slow accretion of gas over time there's
just not enough gas and there's just not
enough time
gives us a new mystery to solve how do
you make black holes that are just that
big there's not a clear answer so far as
to how these Ultra massive black holes
were formed people wonder if there's
some other mechanism by which you could
make black holes a mechanism so violent
it also throws supermassive black holes
clean out of galaxies